my name is Stefan branch am an efficacy
of the nationally person think of
Mozambique and I've been coming to the
World Economic Forum for a few years now
all over the world and the importance of
the floorings that it brings the
attention to the social political and
economic issues country in the region at
stake and I have been fortunate
participate in many sessions roundtables
and discussions focus on real problems
and where the people discussing with the
people that are talking in the people
are dying the audience actually have
acknowledged about the situation have
not only a policy level knowledge mr. to
acknowledge but also a detailed down to
earth situation analysis part one is
happening what is what are the main
problems of the people in the regional
and global so it's really a privilege to
be able to hear such people and to think
joint me about it and I problems which
are very real in such complex you
overwhelmed as the one we have
particularly in South America imagine it
is growing so much in able me during the
forum to cooking so many meters and from
here President Carter on speaking about
the developments in Mexico and very good
things that have happened and also the
challenges that remain in the future
challenges for the country but also
Prime Minister RI and many other
presidents and prime ministers of
several countries as well as experts
from several industries and several
specialties it was always very
refreshing we will understand their
beauty perspectives and to be able to
contribute on a positive note to the
solution of some of these problems
within your ability performance and it
brings together not only political
figures or business leaders but also
also media and social activists in
environmental scientists and that brings
diapers
technique which are not as well
relations in the office